le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais le dessin la
peinture la sculpture la photo voilà
diverses façons d'exprimer ses
sentiments ses idées sa vie et ses rêves
avec quelques pinceaux et un peu de
peinture on peut se lancer dans la
composition d'une toile mais lorsque
l'on veut exposer son art au plus grand
nombre
on se retrouve souvent dans l'impasse
entre coûts de location de salles et
qualité des oeuvres
on a parfois besoin d'un coup de main
pour y arriver alors vers qui se tourner
lorsque l'on a envie d'exprimer son art
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
le concours célimène et au concours
réservé aux femmes réunionnaises
amateurs d'art et n'ayant jamais exposé
de façon professionnelle
une opportunité pour elle de montrer
leur talent et leur savoir faire à des
professionnels me guy est la lauréate du
concours célimène 2014
pour elle la peinture est une passion
peu importe la structure où les couleurs
comme iggy décide de peindre ou de
dessiner
il faut qu'elle le fasse une passion qui
a débuté alors qu'elle était encore à
l'école
alors j'ai commencé à dessiner depuis le
collège avec l'art plastique rapport à
une prof que j'aimais bien j'avais une
bande d'amis qui était très fan de tout
ce qui dit manga être donc je me suis un
peu plongé l'attend la culture japonaise
et où donc un moment donné le dessin
vieux que ma soeur ma grande soeur elle
toujours dessiné elle est super drôle
donc j'ai voulu faire un peu comme elle
et je me suis lancée tend donc à chaque
fois que j'en ai envie
des petits moments où je m'ennuie
j'étais si cette passion en fait c'était
un défouloir
ben c'est pas vraiment un passe-temps du
qu'un passe temps c'est comme si j'en
avais un peu rien à faire ou caen quand
je m'ennuie c'est également que j'ai
envie de dessiner je prends la peinture
je prends du poids je prends tout ce
qu'il me fasse pas là mais même si j'ai
pas vraiment les outils qu'il faut et je
me mets à dessiner j'essaie de faire un
bon truc je préfère à patcher viennent
beaucoup les couleurs mais comme je sais
pas trop bien marié couleurs et en fait
je suis plus dans la reproduction avec
mon style donc j'essaie de prendre le
tableau vu que sas par exemple c'est une
reproduction
donc j'essaie de reprendre les tableaux
mais l'ennemi couleurs à moins de voir
si je peux faire a ajouté ma touche
personnelle
le titre de gagnant du concours donne
toujours des ailes et amène à viser plus
haut et limite le concours célimène
réservé aux amateurs n'est pas une fin
en soi bien au contraire
son souhait est de continuer et
peut-être concrétiser ses rêves alors
par rapport à ce calme après le concours
ça me donne envie de continuer
franchement j'ai envie de me mettre bien
dedans ça me fait mal hespérides
peut-être un jour je fais beaucoup plus
que ça et non je continue j'aimerais
bien en fait continue dans cette voie là
et m'améliorer pour nassimah dindar la
présidente du conseil général
le concours célimène qui fête cette
année ses dix ans est une manière
originale de célébrer la journée
internationale de la femme chaque 8 mars
c'est une initiative qui permet aux
femmes de s'exprimer artistiquement
ce concours permet de célébrer la femme
autrement que par des journées de
sensibilisation sur les violences faites
aux femmes ou autres événements qui ne
traitent pas forcément de la force des
femmes il y a dix ans quand j'ai été élu
président du conseil général je ne
voulais pas qu'on célèbre la femme
seulement sur les violences faites aux
femmes
c'est un vrai combat un enjeu que nous
continuer à accompagner n'ai pas parlé
des femmes
il fallait aussi laisser parler les
femmes est la meilleure façon que de
laisser c'était de lancer ce concours
pour des artistes femmes amateurs et ce
concours connaît un grand succès nous
avons fêté son 10e anniversaire en
changeant aussi la vie de ces femmes qui
peuvent s'exprimer qu'ils peuvent
exposer qui peuvent confronter avec des
professionnels également
leur relais en tous les cas leur volonté
créatrice et créative 15 ans
le concours s'est dit men est une
initiative de nassimah dindar afin que
chaque fans puissent montrer son talent
au travers de l'art c'est également une
réelle occasion de célébrer la femme en
général
le concours célimène rassemble chaque
année plus de 200 participantes
un moment unique et une perspective
incroyable pour celles qui souhaitent
continuer dans cette voie et peut-être
vivre de leur art
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais